hi I'm Brian grant I'm the principal
engineer at Google I'm also a founding
member of the CNCs technical Oversight
Committee just came off of a Q&A panel
for the scenes yet TOC the TOC es job is
to curate the set of projects in the CNC
F to make sure that they help advance
the cloud native mission of the
foundation and also to help those
projects succeed so that latter part
helping the project succeed is an
increasing focus of the TFC as we try to
figure out how to identify what services
the PATA team from the foundation and
how we can help the project's attract
new contributors and maintain errs if
you look at the set of projects like
criminales prometheus fluency gr PCE
open tracing an open telemetry is a
recent project that has been involved
with the that portfolio of projects is
really about helping operators users
developers manage applications with high
velocity at scale predictably and safely
with minimal amounts of toil so as we
look towards the future with additional
projects it might take them to the
foundation we'll be looking for projects
to fill gaps in that portfolio where
users operators developers really need a
solution that fits with the other
projects you have so if you're
interested in talking about those topics
and you're here keep time come by the
Google papi
[Music]
[Applause]